- A guy is almost always gonna finish.
I don't think a girl
is always gonna finish.
Like two pumps in, he's...
- That is the most accurate statement.
(sexy rock music)
(clock ticking)
- I don't put into thought,
like, as I'm getting into sex,
I'm ready for this to last
eight minutes and 45 seconds.
- Duration can be really important
but it's not the end all be all.
Satisfaction is the end all be all.
- I don't think it's as
important as quality.
- To me it's not very
important if it's short
or really long.
I think it's like, if you're
attentive to my needs,
I'll be attentive to yours
and your pleasures and all that stuff.
Ew, it sounds so weird that
I'm saying this right now.
Mom, I'm sorry.
(sexy dance music)
- I said, I think too short
is probably two minutes.
- Point five minutes, so
like 30 seconds, maybe.
- I said five seconds.
- I said a minute and 30.
- By 30 seconds, but if
you do cum in 30 seconds,
be open with your partner.
Figure out other things that you enjoy.
- Under four minutes is like.
- Adequate is like three
minutes so just double that.
- Adequate, 3 to 10 minutes,
cause that doesn't include foreplay.
- I put like 10 minutes.
- Adequate I'd say is about 25.
- 20 minutes maybe.
- I said like 10 minutes.
- For the too long it would be an hour.
- Definitely more than 90 minutes.
- Too long, I think anything
like pure penetration,
I feel like after six minutes
is just like, alright.
- Too long, (laughs) 45 minutes.
- Over 15 minutes.
- Like an hour.
- I would say an average is maybe eight?
- I think it's five minutes.
- Probably two to three minutes
is probably the average.
- I think the average time is 11 minutes.
- Average, 26 seconds.
- That's very specific.
- You have to think of how many
young people are having sex,
who don't know what they're doing.
(clock ticking)
- The truth about sex comes
in a white manila envelope.
(hands drumming)
- Oh.
- One to two minutes was too short.
- That makes sense.
You went under, and I went over.
- 30 seconds is also too short.
(laughing)
- Adequate is three to seven minutes.
- Okay.
- Like, just in the sweet spot,
enough time to get it done.
- What?
That's barely any different.
- Do we have really,
abnormally high expectations?
- Three to ten.
- I was over.
- But that means that we
are getting adequate dick.
- Too long is 10 to 30 minutes.
- Well, you know, (laughing)
I was creating a story in my head.
Alright, it was romantic, we were in love.
- 10 minutes is too long?
Who are they asking?
- Yeah, 15, 45 minutes is too long.
- 45 minutes is way too long.
- Average time,
5.4 minutes.
Look at you.
Well, you know what, I
can't argue with that.
(crickets chirping)
- 5.4 minutes is...
This is fine.
- Everything's fine.
- I don't think that
there is any reason to
be ashamed of how long you last in bed.
I think as long as you're
communicating openly
and making sure that you're
both getting what you need,
then it's fine.
- In sex, there's just so much anxiety,
and it sucks, and
there's so much pressure.
That's where the problem lies then,
cause there's so much expectation.
- There's no need for worrying.
It should be about enjoying
each other's bodies
and just having fun.
- Do some fun things that
extend the length of everything,
and then the person probably
won't even notice that
the literal penetration
to cumming, for you,
was only very short.
- Based on a 2008 study in The
Journal of Sexual Medicine.
(laughs)
- The Journal of Sexual Medicine.
- [Jared] I need to subscribe to that.
- [Maggie] Oh yeah.
(silly pop music)